у всіх лісах ще в румунську
трансільванії мишкою на бішоп європі та
жак буравит миттю зазвучати відвари на
живу далеко відійських посилай про ти їх
не населення збилася нині тут допомогти
із тисяч ведмедів теж гарріс знаходять
я, що забив їх, стежив за можем і лісом.
популяції піти та я забув та до
тут же ви за багато відьма і div там
викрадення вже доходить на весь та силва краю
адже народжуються звільнення доставка зайвих
фірм тільки ти ж не в тому вигнути
напавши на скотину firenza беру
до стоїть мета про баб нудьгувати кулінара
все про рис ти хіба хто вас тут
вийду сліди яких тиф аліни ви шо там у
вінець of двері напавши на моїх гриф над
цим у нападок ось ми div так вже я правий
на з самих людей а дживан і часто ви
кидають сміття на уколи тих своїх посилай
від міді всі і дні теж відходи для них
ласо шмоточок
бурі в 1 де може ніби повинен і
безтурботним і для людей по парі джаю
флоренс імідж зад міністра theme з його
силища вин регулярно перевіряючи з хуртовини
контейнер і багатий зико їх помістив
кліткою проте ціни завжди запах і ж
кивка живин ось мої 10 там і до долин
забезпеч нижчими поважати в асоціації
думки все в румунії причина вирішення їх
нікель кістки говорив про нішу дозволялося
а б це дістав 1 дивно рик на іж
поливання на них за барона на чому горіхи
відзначимо ж на боятися людей чоловік
їх напали вич ти можеш закінчити і
сипуха ну і йшла фермера на фінал ціль
людина за вдівця мало проблеми sleeve
team леонардо берецький зависне правд
варинтів ахи викликати медив самої вінс
при явку хвала ніс оборони заповнюючи ось
ми єдині такі страшні здається і
тугіше та жах покине а колоди дружини
творили давай та ну ще бару тих
областях румунії ось міді проходить самий
на смерть і викликав ще
ви не нападають на людей і дуже ритку
думаю навпаки обіцяно bespeco
встановлювати машини та типу влітають у
метрі видно з дня на думку запасних
відвари ми sleeve tee зони спокою
боятися вт радий цей свій бізнес на
поливу не на відьом йди за словом борецьки
підходить захід а steel його почет та
романтика асоціаціям якщо йти по 3 травня
за божа не трав і вид трьох до восьми
тисяч євро ось промінь із лісових і пояснюють
фон і закласти витків цивіки принципу
ливання від романтика влада на нато
пеклу це про них сама на тему місці геть
і часто чікає на відьом і дів разом за
своїм і заміжнім та клієнтами за барона
на полювання на ви думаєте було чесно в
витрата для нас зі знач ного доходу йти в
край на південь види для нашої території
батах щоб іти чим з бан круту йому
ще один нога даний big за барони
напали ваніно ось медів
а б одружилася уникнути cliquez
браконьєрів
ці поллють над їхніми набили та жокеїв
Європи
[музика]